so hello everybody i'm here with dr
mario
vagos some of you who are following all
of this exciting universal history
that i've been doing on my channel have
seen my discussion with him on the
kind of the mythical aspect of
constantinople uh
mario is the uh the author of a very
interesting book on the symbolism
of kings and emperors and from the near
east all the way to
byzantium and so uh he really he's
really
bringing to light the the things that we
want to talk
about in terms of the uh let's say the
more legendary aspect of of these
civilizational motifs
and so today what we want to talk about
together is
this image of the the immortal emperor
the image of the marble
emperor and the notion of this emperor
that kind of goes to sleep or vanishes
and then comes back at the end that we
see
in the byzantine tradition but also we
see in the western tradition in all
kinds of motifs
and we're going to dovetail that into a
discussion about apocalyptic motif
in byzantine thinking so i'm very
excited to
to uh to continue the discussion on
universal history with uh with dr mario
[Music]
bagos
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so dr mario thank you thank you for for
joining me a second time
i know that the reaction to our first
discussion was really really exciting
and people
were were very fascinated by the things
we talked about so i'm looking forward
to our discussion today
likewise jonathan i'm very much uh
honored to be here again and um
and i thank you for for inviting me
again it's a great blessing yeah
so tell us a little bit so i think we
just need to dive right into it so tell
us a little bit about the legends
uh of the the marble emperor and the
different versions of it and
how this kind of ties into universal
history okay well
i was thinking of the best possible
segue into such a vast topic because
it's a big topic
and before the recording we're talking
about the various avenues that we could
uh
take in approaching it but in the 1970s
and your greek uh viewers and listeners
will know about this
the the singer george dalaras
and um harris alexia they released an
album called asia minor migratia
and on this album so this is what 50
years ago 60 years ago there was a song
called the marble king or marmara menos
vasilias
and it talks about uh well hardy
it's a female singer speaking about
sending uh
two birds to the red apple tree to hear
about
news concerning the marble king
the red apple tree is a motif that
appears constantly in the later
byzantine apocalyptic literature it's
either the place where
the arabs or the turks originated from
or on the borders between byzantium and
and um islamic territories
and these red apple trees in a region
where those things that are written
about us are the prophecies and
everything else
and those birds one is killed the other
is wounded and they never return
uh concerning the marble king there has
been no word the song goes on to say
um only uh he's only talked about in the
fairy tales that grandma sings to young
children
so it's the motif of the marvel king is
very much still in the
popular consciousness of the greek
people in 1998 stamatis
who is a um a greek composer
actually he composes a song with a choir
called
he will come like lightning or you will
come like lightning
sun and this song uh
puts together a lot of the motifs
concerning the marble king
constantine dragas paleologos or
constantine the eleventh the final
emperor of byzantium
uh who died defending uh the city from
uh the final onslaught of the ottomans
in 1453
the city of constantinople that we spoke
about in the last video
fell on may 29 1453
and so because of the circumstances
surrounding his death we which we'll
discuss perhaps a little bit later
there are various let's say
i don't know notions attributed to him
the most famous one is that he was
plucked from
the point in which he was defending the
city against the turks
near the saint romanos gate one of the
many gates in the theodosian walls
that were on the landwood side of
constantinople and that
hadn't been breached up until that point
the crusaders
during the fourth crusade managed to get
over them but they were breached for the
first time with cannon fire we discussed
that in the last video
and so he was plucked from that spot
instead of dying
and was taken to the golden gate
theodosius golden gate which was the
main
triumphal entrance into the city and
there
he was turned into marble by an angel
and placed in a subterranean cavern
um where he sleeps in this state of
marble until such a time that he will
rise and
sort of take back the city and all these
sorts of things
um this song uh by spanish brings to the
for
all of the motifs that are associated
with constantine
by leologos
[Music]
king of kings helped the king vasilev
vasilyan vasily
which are the four beaters that appear
on constantin paleolava's
flag which you've probably seen it's red
and yellow
um mercy mercy heavenly god constantine
constantinos by the grace of god
emperor of the romans
which is the way that he would sign off
his correspondences
at the gate of saint romanos writing his
white-legged beast
a steed story uh four betas
uh which refers to the flag mercy mercy
marble
bosphorus and black tuesday so there's
it's not really a narrative
they're just various kind of images i
mean taken and thrown together in this
song that was just in 1998
um but the you got me thinking
uh in preparation for this uh podcast
what would let's say compel
a christian civilization of course not
authored not all orthodox were expecting
the return of the marble king
uh immediately after the fall of
constantinople um
it's more of let's say a superstition on
a folkloric sort of level like a popular
thing
it's not something that uh either the
saints of the church would really speak
about
or fathers or literati or anything like
that so
what would make them desire the return
of
the last emperor byzantium when the king
had come already and has come already
and will come again as we recite in
every divine liturgy in the nicene creed
we expect the resurrection of the dead
and the life of the age to come the
second coming of our lord jesus christ
and he's already come so you know why
the need to think about or to desire to
expect
a terrestrial ruler to set everything
straight for us
when the terrestrial ruler might be
fixing the let's say sociopolitical
circumstances or something
like that restoring a worldly kingdom
right irrespective of what that kingdom
was constantinople of course was in
endowed with much spirituality too and
so is the byzantine empire
but why expect the king to restore a
worldly kingdom when you have the
ruler of the kings of the earth our lord
jesus christ that's the way he's
referred to in the book of
revelation um who's defeated
death itself in his person with his
resurrection on the third day
and within the framework of the church
the orthodox church we believe
uh endows us with the let's say the
grace to participate in his victory over
death
so if i can go to my local orthodox
church and participate in its rhythms
and its sacraments
and have a foretaste however sinful i am
of the resurrectional life that christ
the king of kings the ruler of the kings
of the earth gives to each and every
member of his body the church why will i
need a uh
a terrestrial ruler to come back so
that's what i've been wrestling with
um and mostly because that motif is not
just there in constantinople because it
there are legends now i'm learning there
are legends in almost every single
christian
nation that has this idea whether it's
charlemagne
or uh i think it's barbarossa and like
all these different
these different kings or our king arthur
that is also kind of waiting in avalon
to return so it seems like this motif is
uh
is one which is all over the the
christian civilization
and and uh the example in constantinople
is just one
kind of shining example of that of of
that legend or that motif let's say
that's right it's a shining example it's
a very fascinating example
i'll tell you i'm brought to tears
nearly every time i returned to um
to reading about the uh the circumstance
that led to the fall of the city and
and the death of its final emperor he
was truly a heroic figure
um he's not a saint but he's a heroic
figure and we can maybe discuss a little
bit later
he's not considered a saint but uh if we
look at this motif
there must be something abiding
because we're talking about universal
history and we can also do universal
history which is what you do so
you know uh contemplating this approach
um
i was led to um i had written in the
past the announce historians the french
historians
jacques legoff and george to be who
speak about
the structures mental and psychological
structures
that change only very gradually over
long periods of time
long dure and this motif of
the final king the final emperor is one
of the of those
uh richard you know who is um he's doing
great work in this uh
in this area with you in in the previous
podcasts
uh he basically narrowed everything down
to
you know this uh this book here the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius
as being that watershed text that
standardizes the byzantine
and let's say western medieval
image of the the last king the king who
will return to put things
right just before the second coming of
christ if we're going to just hone in a
little bit more
in terms of the definition so uh he's
absolutely correct i've been returning
to this material and trying to trace
the various trajectories that it that it
leads to both in the east and in the
west
but um today with you i think we can go
um
a step further back in time before we
move forward in time
because a lot of this has to do with the
way time functions and is perceived of
and experienced
in the middle ages and in the ancient
world and we should look at
the ruler cult which is uh let's say
something it's a phenomenon that is uh
associated with the rise of civilization
at least in recorded history in relation
to recorded history
the propensity to venerate and even
worship the ruler the king the emperor
the pharaoh whatever you want to call
him
as a god as a deity um shall we go down
that
path yeah i mean i think that that's
important mostly because
can i say this mostly because the king
because the first of all the image of
christ
is is an image of kingship you know this
descendant of david
the the image of king david is also an
image of the kind of high point of
israel you know even though it has its
faults to it
david and solomon are the high point in
the story of israel
uh you know the building of the temple
all that is related also to kingship and
so i think it's important to see
how let's say how it existed it's been
existed for millennia and then
also how it was transformed in the in
the christian story let's say i think
that's that's
definitely important well i'm so glad
you mentioned uh king david and um
the history of israel because that's
precisely where things change
you know he's not a god i mean it's
palpable it's clear that he has
weaknesses he has thoughts he's a
servant
of the most high god and so are his
successes
meant to be he's distinguished by his
repentance of course
um but uh and he's also his glory is
in in whatever aspect of him is servant
of god that's where
his glory is and then in all those
aspects where
he is acting like almost he's acting
like any other king would have let's say
just by doing his own thing and taking
women and doing all that
then he is seen as being faultful
and and needs to repent on that on that
front let's say
well that's right that that's so
important for the whole uh penitential
tradition and um
and christian worship and experience
isn't it i mean and it's all refracted
through christ
um whom david anticipates according to
the flesh
so all of this is that's where we're
headed but we'll go back let's say to
okay sumeria or mesopotamia i mean
that happens to some of the material
that i address in my book and i i
also address king david um
in the historical record uh it's in the
2400 bc around there
where we have two rulers of agade which
is a mesopotamian city a civilization
that flourished there
um sargon and naram sin
who are seen as representatives of
ishtar
the goddess and ishtar uh was supposed
to hold
in her hands the principles of being for
all of creation the meh or the mez
in plural something like the logos and
the logi but not articulated in such a
philosophical
or even in such an existentially
meaningful way not as yet
um they were participants in this
what we could call demiurgic activity of
ishtar so
by demiurge creator deity
four state he's considered demons from
the perspective of the church okay so we
acknowledge all of that but
we're just looking at the trend of
thinking here it's the earliest example
that we have of the ruler cult
of the ruler being worshiped as a god
either because they represent
the goddess in this case or they
participate in the god or goddesses
world shaping activity and this is
reflected primarily
in architecture ziggurats you know that
represent the cosmic mountain so what
the ruler kind of does
is he reinitiates the cosmogony the
creation of the world i spoke about this
last time
and this is even clearer in egypt which
is
almost simultaneously if not a couple
hundred years later
you have the pharaohs
recapitulating the cosmos within their
temples and
acting as servants participants and
embodiments of the demiurge in this
this process the most emphatic example
is
you know uh the constant experience of
the egyptians was
when the nile floods everything is chaos
so chaos and cosmos come into this
the king generates cosmos to stave off
chaos
and there are deities that are agents of
cosmos the demiurge being the principal
one
there are also deities that are agents
of chaos so uh when the
flood waters recede little hillocks was
seen throughout the course of the nile
and the egyptians transposed his
experience onto their creation myths and
said well at the beginning there was the
formless expanse the waters of chaos the
nun
those receded and a hilly merge which
represents order
the demiurge simultaneously emerged
posterior to mata and creation
that's an important point to make
because the christian god the
trinitarian god is
anterior to mata and creation because he
creates the world
out of nothing it's a massive revolution
in terms of the history of religions and
the way god is perceived of an
experience how god reveals himself to
the world but anyway
the damage is posterior he does his
shaping and ordering
and the pharaoh participates in that in
various ways whether he's building a
temple whether he's holding a ceremony
or a festival
he's also fighting off the agents of
chaos
but all of this is a retrospective
return to the time of
creation the way that they perceived
creation
this is also the case to an extent uh
with israel the people of israel
except as um is the name of the russian
uh author that you had with you recently
also
yes he speaks about the judeo-christian
inaugurating a linear view of time
um in the video and that's true
it's not it's not exclusive to
judeo-christianity
and judaic christianity is in fact
multi-layered because although you see
a linear view of time manifested there's
in
time moving forward towards an expected
outcome
uh transformation of the world or
something like that um
the uh heavenly kingdom in christianity
can be participated in which is the
eternal kingdom
at each and every divine service so
eternity and the linear
uh let's say duration of space intersect
okay
we talked about it as being kind of like
a spiral like it's not it's
it's it's it's kind of the joining of a
circular in the sense of of
there's a sense in which the the
eschaton
is a return to paradise but it's also
above it's also above paradise there's a
there's there is the circularity in even
in
that that's what you did you did talk
about it yeah there is a circularity but
it's not a it's not this
eternal return it's really is like a
let's say an upward spiral
um of movement so yeah anyways
perfect that's right it's not an eternal
return the myth of the eternal return
is what mircheliade uh used to describe
the sort of phenomena i was just talking
about in
the mesopotamia but in uh although you
have it
in in israel for instance the the temple
of um in jerusalem the temple uh is a
recapitulated
uh recapitulation of eden uh in the
genesis narrative so
the monumental pillars jaqen and boaz
represent the tree of life and the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil and so
on and so forth
and you have this recapitulation of
that sacred pastime in the present but
there's this linear trajectory and
that's
reflected throughout the text that
linear trajectory is there in greece to
the
dawning of more or less a historical
consciousness right
um but you know you have a change in
kingship
providentially in both israel and greece
but the greeks
even though they were cynical towards
their kings let's say at the beginning
of greek civilization classical
civilization in the 800's before that
you have the
um the mycenaeans and then before that
the minoan so
although they're cynical towards their
kings the previous civilizations
you see some cynicism with mycenae um
and that's reflected in
in homer because you know they're all
battling each other and feuding and
feuding and all sorts of things
alexander ruins it all for them
what makes it better whichever
interpretation you want to take
because he represents himself as a god
as a divine world shaping agent and
combines that with the notion of the
philosopher king coming from plato who
was the master of his teacher
aristotle so with the greeks that ends
but with the jews it's persistent
the king is a mortal agent
who serves the only true god who
discloses his will to
the prophets and the king the two
branches that say of
of jewish civilization in order to draw
the people to god you have
from a christian point of view the
disclosure of god as father in a hinting
towards the coming of his son
and david is the paragon there as you
mentioned david is the one who unites
the 12 tribes of
israel david is the one who conceives of
the idea of the the temple which is
built by solomon
to house the ark of the covenant which
is where god
resides david has his failures um
which we just mentioned and he repents
but he becomes the paradigmatic king to
such an extent that
uh it was always expected that kingship
uh in subsequent generations would
imitate the davidic model
um okay until the sixth century when
the babylonian exile happens and the
davidic line is severed forever
kingship is then re-re-thought of then
in order to project it into the future
as a son of david who would come to
restore
israel back to this immediate
relationship with god where everything
was peaceful
where he would execute judgment and
before he could
uh let's say create this just and
peaceful civilization with the temple
and god residing within it in its center
he had to fight off israel's enemies and
liberate them from bondage
and you find this motif motif uh in
ezekiel in isaiah in all of the old
testament uh
there already is a hint at least of
something a pattern which is similar
to this pattern of the returning king or
the you know the idea of the
the broken line which will be restored
or however you want to
to phrase it whether it's the actual
king or
his line that will sprout you know the
the surprising sprout of the king which
appears
um so it seems like there's already a
the motif is there
even in the image of the messiah
as the son of david it's it's there like
so
it's it's even before these medieval
versions of this this
this tradition in the messiah himself
there's something of that
of that trope let's say of the of the
king that fell that
died that disappeared and now will
return at some point to restore things
i couldn't agree with you more it's
there it's there the king's line is
broken the king will come a son of david
will be
raised by god in order to restore the
kingdom uh to israel firstly and
reinitiate this communion with god
but something else sneaks into the
prophecies there and that's disclosed by
god providentially
it's um the fact that the virgin shall
conceive and bear a son and he shall be
called emmanuel
okay what's happening there what version
i mean this is in isaiah right
and then you have micah speaking about
bethlehem as a place where this future
figure will be born
then you have the suffering servant
motive which contrasts to the idea of a
warrior king
okay the one who will take the
iniquities of israel upon himself
and who as a lamb before his sheers
remains silent you know he's
beaten and afflicted for these of the
people
the son of man motif is then made very
explicit in the book of daniel chapter
seven where the son of man
and that's the suffering servant figure
that can be conflated
he's not going to reign over one
particular people as you see in
isaiah and various other prophecies but
he's given authority by the ancient of
days
interpreted by christians as god the
father to reign over all peoples
and all nations and that's christ
because christ identifies himself as the
son of man
he's also identifying himself throughout
his ministry as the son of god
um and as the son of david so son of god
son of man son of david all of these
motifs are then transferred to christ in
various ways we see that in the new
testament
he self-identifies as the son of man
continuously in order to show that he's
precisely this figure
and as his ministry unfolds and widens
let's say even after his ascension into
heaven you see that he's the one
gathering all people
into his uh new community which is the
church
initially a refounding of israel through
the 12 apostles who
are like the 12 tribes of israel
reconstituted
but what kind of a king is he
the master of the cosmos the pando as we
spoke about in the last talk
the son of god the father the lord who
all things came into being
who empties himself chaotically and
assumes
human nature as christ right the humble
king
utterly humble there's no the depths of
humility are
penetrated and encompassed by christ and
that's what that's dramatically
reflected
in the final week of his um life before
his crucifixion and
thereafter his resurrection so riding
into israel on a donkey which is a
despised creature
so on and so forth um my kingdom is not
of this world he's saying to pilate
and uh what does this king well what
does he endow us with
um material goods and glory and uh
no actually uh he endows us with the
conquest
of death itself um and
sin and devil that had the power and the
devil that had the power of above
through his resurrection on the third
day
so different kind of king
the everlasting king what happens
thereafter is something that
we were talking about before jonathan is
that
the church which is the body of christ
as it goes out into the world
as it goes on let's say
its journey to witness to
um to christ and to the fact that he's
inaugurated eternal life in his person
he himself gives the mandate go forth
and baptize all nations
in the name of the father and the son
and the holy spirit and i'll be with you
until the end of the age as
the church does this it encounters
hostility and opposition
from worldly powers worldly kingdoms one
kingdom in particular rome
and if we speak about rome we have to
speak about augustus of course
who is uh the first roman emperor
uh in the same way that alexander was
the first greek king
to uh initiate the rule of cult to call
himself
sacred in perpetuity in his lifetime at
least his uncle had the uh
you know the good sense to be uh made of
god after he died
by the senate exactly yeah that's i
always
but there there's an interesting there's
an interesting moment
because there's also an interesting
moment in the sense that
to understand that christ was was alive
at during the time of augustus that
there is almost this
these two narratives being set up or
these two stories of a divine king
that are that are let's say put in
parallel because it says also that
christ was born
like in the in the bible it's it's made
explicit that he was born
during the time of augustus so there
seems to be
there there right there in scripture
there seems to be
laying up these two images of what of a
divine king let's say
you know one which is truly the divine
king and is hidden in the world almost
like
almost like king david was hidden when
saul was king so saul is this king
and king david is a hidden king that no
one knows about until
his fruits are revealed later but you
get it you get
this so you do get this you do get this
image of of
of these two divine kings let's say the
contrast between these two images
you get a contrasting image which for
apologetic purposes the church will try
to temper and that's reflected as early
as the new testament you know
saint paul appeals to his roman
citizenship christ says render unto
caesar what he sees as unto god what is
god's
um you know saint paul says elsewhere
pray for your rulers
at the same time these rulers are
presenting themselves as divine
and when christians refuse to take that
extra step which is to worship them as
gods to pour
libations on their statues and like
incense to them
they're murdered they're killed these
are the martyrs who die as intercessors
to christ as you know
and reign with him forever but the
the interesting thing is now you have
two trajectories set up
um a kind of more conciliatory approach
towards the world
because after all the world has to be
baptized for christ right
and one which is a bit more perceptive
of the underlying reality behind the
world outside the church
which is let's say in its fallen state a
satanic or demonic one
and this is reflected in the book of
revelation which you've discussed um
uh before um
the uh now we're gonna talk about the
scholars and i don't know whether
but um the scholars like to say that uh
the two beasts one that comes out of the
sea and one comes out of the
the earth in the book of revelation that
are raised by the devil which is the
other beast
many beasts and who can keep track of
how many heads they have and horns and
and everything else right but um the one
that comes out of the sea
is the roman imperial cult and the
emperors generally who
demand to be worshipped as gods and the
one that
comes out of the earth is the priesthood
encouraging people because that's what
the second beast does it encourages
people to worship the first beast yeah
that's right so
um and then the two witnesses there
enoch and elijah
they're interpreted as enoch and elijah
and that's the martyrs generally uh
simultaneously so what you have
is a possession of the roman ruler cult
as uh
evil and rome is identified with babylon
and all these sorts of things
and um this came directly out of the
christians experience they were being
massacred we know that the
nero um in order to find a scapegoat for
the fire that he himself lit and burned
down
much of rome uh put christians on uh
spikes and burnt them alive
um so we know we know that um
that there was this kind of uh hostility
towards what had come into the world the
light that had come into the world with
christ and which was being disseminated
through his apostles and and and the
churches that they established
uh the apostles 11 of the 12 are
martyred of course
the exception of saint john saints peter
and paul are martyred in rome famously
during the reign of the emperor nero and
so we have
um all of this happening and martyrdom
is a paradoxical phenomenon
we lament the deaths of the martyrs but
they participate
immediately in the kingdom of christ in
the eternal kingdom so they are
translated to paradise forever now well
this is happening but you know the
church will still
in the intervening let's say decades and
centuries
be declaiming the romans for unlawful
unlawfully putting them to death and
casting aspersions about
you know uh their behavior and you know
the sacraments and all these sorts of
things which the romans had
misinterpreted
and at the same time they're trying to
encourage them to
uh you know we pray for you uh you know
uh we wish you all the best but we're
not gonna worship you
and it's this back and forth and you
find that in the apologetic literature
minutes
felix in the in the west and st justin
mata famously in the yeah
that's really important to me this point
that you made is very important because
there's a sense let's say in popular
understanding and in
i would say in kind of modern
understanding that if these things are
in opposition
that there there's a sense in which the
people they tend to decry rome or decry
the emperor decry the king
in modern thinking kind of modern
democratic thinking
uh as being opposed to god necessarily
the very k the very in the idea of
kingship or the very idea of
authority is somehow wrong and we need
to
worship god and then be suspicious of of
authorities right especially in american
culture
you kind of have that that sense but the
christians
even the early christians even though
they were martyred even though they were
persecuted
they would still say obey the rule
but this like except for this they were
they were seen as model citizens
except for the fact that they refused to
participate in pagan cults and worship
the the emperor but for all roman laws
they were they would tell christians to
obey the laws obey the rules you know
follow what the these authorities are
given to you by god
but we will not participate in the the
aspects of them which are psychologists
and which are
which are demonic but we but we still
recognize them as being given to us by
god and so
there's a key in there where it is that
when suddenly the authorities become
christian
then suddenly there is no reason there
is no reason to continue to
oppose the rulers because they were
already subject to them and already
obeying their rules
yeah well this is a fascinating point
and actually
you know the providential arrangement of
all things if we believe that
providence grace and god's presence
is there in all events and all factors
in life
i mean that doesn't make him a causal
agent in all of them so that people
don't you know associate
um persons in in all things with you
know the uh
him causing people to die or something
like that we need to be careful and
that's actually another topic of the
odyssey but um because providence
arranges things to bring about
ultimately a good end for as many people
that
choose to respond freely to this
providential let's say outreach that god
does for each and every one of us right
then he permits the circumstances
including
uh the governments and kingships of the
past
and because of our fallen state because
we you know we
have our passions and our sins and we
don't want to repent and turn to god
he permits um even the martyrdoms that
took place there because without those
martyrdoms i mean
we can decry them and you know it's a
horrible thing that the apostles were
killed
from their point of view perhaps it's
not as bad saint paul says i can't wait
you know
i'd rather be with christ and disappear
in the body not that the martyrs and
see it's all very slippery slopey
because
uh the martyrs were discouraged from
actively seeking martyrdom
right when these one or two examples
came up later on
um but because god discloses even to the
martyrs that they will die as martyrs
this creates an incredible testimony
martis is witness
a witness which brings more and more
people to the gospel and
initiates them into the life of christ
so the martyrs
as they die go from this world to the
next only forever those who they bring
with them
at the moment of their martyrdom live
forever with them and this
in the early days included pagans who
converted on the spot
you know um and the testimony kind of
extends beyond that to people who read
the materologies who venerate them in
church you know we have this
panoply this great cloud of witnesses if
you like that intercede for us so
even the the roman empire persecuting
the
the saints from a certain point of view
was good for the church
but don't misinterpret me i'm saying
this more to the listeners you know i
mean
yeah well it's a christ says scandal
must happen but woe to those by whom it
happens it's
it's not a praise of scandal but there's
an understanding in which
these events and these these deaths act
as
as seeds for the future world uh but it
doesn't justify those that killed them
the martyrs and those that did those
horrible things it doesn't thank you for
pointing that out
but then what happens after that that
period of let's say intermittent
persecution
up until our favorite person comes along
saying constant in the grave is here
um what did he say that we're the three
people who still uh love constance still
have constantine yeah
that's right but look
i'll tell you what uh jonathan i really
do believe at the moment
in 315 a.d so he'd been a christian
officially for three years you know
after seeing um the uh in dutonica
by the sun conquering the sky and
defeating maxentius and
you know he's in rome and they're
erecting that triumphal arch to him
next to the coliseum the amphitheater of
larvian
and constantine refuses to participate
in the sacrifices to jupiter that is a
fulcrum point in world history right
there and there are a lot of moments
like that in the reign of constantine so
you know i mean for a roman emperor to
go no
you know to be disgusted with this kind
of uh behavior idolatrous behavior
it's just it's it's a changing point
anyway i'm curious
one question i have is also about the
art about the emperor worship
him itself and so was there a change
during the time of constantine because
we know that from the time of augustus
it seems like
the the emperor seemed to have that
almost
almost inevitably have this title as as
god himself or son of god or some kind
of
divine title and so is there something
that to help us understand how
constantine reacted to that tradition
well look some people say that he might
have committed sacrifices to be done in
his uh
image in various uh territories in the
empire but there's
there's no way that that would have
happened in those territories
in which he was erecting uh christian
churches almost everywhere uh
in and around rome constantinople the
holy land so he's a transitionary figure
which means that
he needed to placate the pagans while at
the same time
christianizing the topography he
retained the title pontifex maximus the
greatest bridge
between heaven and earth which was not
uh relinquished by emperors until either
gratian or theodosius gave it to
pope really the ma with the masses
yes and i'm pretty sure it's theodosius
because he was incredibly uh
pious yeah he gave over the title of
pontifex maximus is not befitting
the the emperor interesting yeah yeah so
constantine still had it but you know
you need to put the man in his context
it would be unfair to say just because
he still had it
that he demanded to be worshipped in the
same way that caligula did
or something like that you know these
two things do not stand together
uh especially in light of all of the
other uh pro-church things he did that
we discussed last time so
there's no chance i think in dwelling on
those but constantine changed the game
and then in the fourth century
immediately after his reign we get the
first
apocalyptic text which was already
mentioned by richard that speaks about
a final king and that's the tibiatine
sybil if i'm pronouncing
uh it right now the symbols being the
oracles the roman oracles who spoke
about future events
and and you've already addressed them at
length but this is the interesting bit
i've got the quote here that refers to
the name
and it's the only text in late antiquity
and in the byzantine period that refers
to this final king a final emperor by
name
um and it goes like this then we'll
arise a king of the greeks
at the end times and always the end
times are preceded by uh devastation
destruction and all these sorts of
things
um that lead to a final renewal that
christ says this about the end times as
well
but what we need to before i read this
it's important to mention what we
need to articulate in relation to the
christian
experience is that christ has
already within himself objectively
accomplished everything that will
unilaterally and universally happen at
the end
which is the transformation of the
universe in light of his kingdom
the final judgment of the righteous of
the unrighteous the defeat of the devil
and sin and death
they've already happened in his person
with his resurrection
ascension into heaven and while it's
happened in him
objectively all these things that
happened in him objectively
they unfold subjectively within his body
the church
when people participate in the sacred
rhythms of the church through repentance
participation in the sacraments prayer
and the
the proof of this we have the saints who
are able to do by christ's grace
what he did and does
uh but not to the same extent that yeah
well i i i think that for a lot of
people watching this
that watch my channel understand this
fractal pattern
which is that you know that christ and
christ
first of all plants us a seed which
contains the pattern in itself
and then also has the cosmic pattern in
the end which will be kind of the
totality
of of in the incarnation playing itself
out cosmically
and then it plays out at different level
levels whether it is in the lives of the
saints
whether it is in the liturgical year it
is our own participation in the liturgy
and then also even historically plays
out in these mini cycles where you see
little images of the kingdom of god
appearing in different places in the
world where
there are moments where things seem to
to come together and we see like in the
example of constantinople where
constantinople is a little image of the
new jerusalem
it's not a complete image it has still
has its fault it still
has it it's uh it's its difficulties but
it nonetheless
is a little glimpse and a little fractal
version of the
the giant cosmic one that we see in in
revelation
and that's a beautiful way to put it so
i mean that that's the standard now and
so everything that we're looking at uh
from this point onwards in relation to
the final emperor
is a deviation from that standard in
some
it can be a benign deviation right
because you know the the final king is
not christ therefore
you know it's something that christians
from a liturgical
perspective uh from the point of view of
the the
essence of the life of the church they
don't expect it but it comes up in
popular culture it comes up in times of
stress and anxiety and desperation
and and this is why it's important to
to understand it so that you know when
we do endure difficult circumstances we
don't
we aren't beguiled and necessarily into
thinking that the solution
is in you know many cri mania for
false christ and antichrist have indeed
come is what um
saint john says in the in his epistles
and that plays out throughout history
especially
around the time of the reformation but
we we might talk about that later so
returning back to the tibriton uh sybil
then will arise the king of the greeks
his name is constance
he will be king of the romans and the
greeks and he will be told of stature of
handsome appearance and shining face
etc so describes his physique it
describes
the fact that he's king of the romans
and the greeks greco-roman civilization
roaming compass greece but why constance
uh you know i couldn't get past it
because i looked through this book by
paul j
alexander the byzantine apocalyptic
tradition that analyzes this text
briefly and i couldn't
i couldn't find a solution we do have a
constans in the fourth century
immediately what happened after the
death of constantine
and let's let's to answer this question
we have to look
a little bit at the end of his reign so
constantine did a lot of good stuff at
the church he's a saint of the church i
accept that you know venerate him
because of um
of all that he accomplished and you know
the inner life of a person no one can
know so
let's just accept tradition and not the
eight million other constantines in
scholarship that we get right
um and uh he
gets he described in his war with
lycenius his
final rival emperor because he basically
um demolished the tetraki the rule of
the four emperors that uh
uh was set up by diocletian the
persecuting emperor the one who
initiated the great persecution just
before
constantine's reign and lycenius was one
of the last to go
he refers to him in his letters
the dragon lycenius assimilating him to
the dragon
which is the chaos entity the monster
the devil in this sense
and according to eusebius's life of the
emperor and you see mrs caesarea
i love you cebus he's very important but
he's also incredibly problematic
because he does all of that uh
pagan panigalizing of the emperor which
gives the emperor a bad name actually
that's part of the reason why
uh eusebius uh had a mixed reception in
byzantium but
everybody read his history his history
is one of the most important works of
playing antiquity so
um in his life of constantine which goes
well beyond the norms of
any rising constantine he describes a
panel
set above the entrance to constantine's
palace in constantinople
which had on it the crystagram the cairo
a land so the cairo was on top of a
javelin
and on the lance was like a crossbar
with a um a portrait of constantine and
his three sons
and this lance was driving the serpent
into the abyss
so you can interpret this um as uh
spiritually you know through the reign
of the christian
uh emperor um uh
the evil is being or spiritual evil is
being kept at bay
through the churches he built all these
sorts of things and that's fine
but there's also a historicist way of
interpreting this as
the emperor defeating his terrestrial
enemies and they are the actual
uh evil ones not the evil behind them
and all of us that attempts us to sin
which the only real enemy of the
christian people along with death
so you know um
this particular image uh
what is it well what do you do with it
yeah well
the interesting thing about it is that
it seems at least the image like let's
say if you take the symbol is the very
symbolism of the image
itself and we don't try to give it um we
don't try to interpret it historically
like
what the dragon is it's a dragon let's
say it's just a dragon
there's a sense in which this could be
an image of the proper
emperor right so you have above at the
top you have this image of christ
as the i really as the son of god as the
the son of man as this
cosmic virgin of the king and then below
then you have
a an image of the actual king and his
descendants
who are below the image of christ that
are kind of let's say being a tool or
or an image of of of christ and then
then they becoming a tool for christ
in the world to to vanquish evil or to
push away
the the the evil aspects of reality so
that's one way
then the other way the cynical way is of
course to see
the emperor as using christ to justify
whatever that they want to do
politically
which is that which is those are the two
images of of civilization let's say and
you always hear one version you hear the
version
that especially in modern times we hear
the cynical version
you know that that let's say kings and
the church or whatever
use the excuse of god or christ to then
do whatever it is they wanted to do and
to
defeat their enemies but i think that we
always need to
be able to understand the two
interpretations
because it is also true that god uses
our our civil authorities uses the
powers of the world
to hold chaos at bay because without
civilization you know we would be eaten
i i know because i've lived in places
where civilization was breaking down
and where states were fallen and it
doesn't look like a
nice you a nice happy a world where
people hold hands it looks like a bunch
of warlords
that will come and take whatever they
want and you have no way of stopping
them
and so there is a there is an the
reality of civilization can really be a
tool for god to
bring about a kind of peace in the world
i agree with you i agree with you 100
and actually
what you mentioned about the way
civilization is used to generate
order out of chaos is another apologetic
motif
that's used by minutius felix and others
that uh
uh providentially christ is one actually
we chant this and i don't remember in
which um
in which service christ is
providentially born during the reign of
augustus
the one who united the disparate king
and this is augustus who's
let's face it idolatrous right you know
so he's
he he calls himself sacrosanctus
i am holy perpetually in his um
gusty the uh the epic graph
um epigram that uh was distributed
throughout the
the empire he intended it for being
distributed after he died in greek and
latin but anyway
but even under him right because he
manages to unite
all of the warring and disparate
factions
[Music]
this multiplicity and divisive
multiplicity
seen as diabolical his
unifying agency is
in the background behind the scenes
engendered by god
so that not directly not as
you know like so that we don't confuse
christ augustus but behind the scenes
god allows this unification to happen so
that christ
the one true king of everybody can be
born within a relatively peaceful
context so that's an apologetic motif
and it's uh uh it's recurrent in the
early period and
still in the church but uh look the fact
that
the lava or the lava room that's what
this uh
image is in constantine's palace of the
speed javelin the
the snake or the dragon the lava is
still used in orthodox services
points to the fact that it is the
spiritual interpretation because we have
the lava
not necessarily with constantine with
the resurrected christ on it
we have at my parish at saint
catherine's uh saint catherine on the
lavaro
and so on and so forth and we process it
it's a spiritual tool it's
the roman let's say standard
spiritualized and that's fine because
the church did that with a lot of things
so
but what we um what we have with uh
happening in the fourth century
thereafter is precisely the cynical
approach that you mentioned
picked up by constantine's successor
he's one of his sons and that cynical
approach inaugurates a trajectory
whereby the ruler cult is rehabilitated
under the aryan kings that govern
intermittently throughout the fourth
century until theodosius the great
another awesome emperor if we're going
to be extilling constantine we have to
extol
theodosius as well okay they're about
saying to the church in any case
theodosius comes along and he puts an
end to all of this but
that's in 381 constantine dies in 337
and in the into nicene period 325 is the
castle of nicaea
2381 the second ecumenical council in
constantinople
it's like all hell broke loose against
the council of nicaea
that affirmed that christ is one essence
with the father fully god because if
he's not fully god and thus
and eternal in such a way he cannot save
us
liberate us from the opposite of
eternity which is death
okay so the church had already
experienced and always experienced
christ as
fully guarded eternally but it
articulated this in a specific way
at the council of nicaea all hell breaks
loose against his council
and saint athanasius um the bishop of
alexandria
athanasius the great um is the
locus of a lot of this antagonism
because he's the great champion of
nicaea in this period
again he's misinterpreted by scholars
they've done a lot of damage to
athanasius's reputation but on my
academia page you can find
a chapter and an article uh that
rehabilitates the traditional approach
to ethanasius
and and it's it's more sound than what
scholars come
up with why am i talking about
athanasius who is exiled five times in
the 300s by aryan kings
who in fact points out their their use
of the ruler cult
because arianism is more palatable to
the rule of cult
if christ is made a the highest of all
created beings because that's what
arianism
posits that he's a creature he's not of
one essence with the father and thus
eternal and god in the same way that god
the father is god
but if he's a creature i'll be at the
highest creature
nevertheless he's a bit closer to the
emperor don't you think
because he's on this side of the
ontological gap between the uncreated
and the created if he's in one essence
of the father he's uncreated in the way
that the father is uncreated eternal
divine
what is distinct is his personhood but
he shares the same nature and essence
with the father
and the spirit does the same but if he's
on this side of the created order well
the emperor can still go about
masquerading as
divine and he does that constantius
constant sun
because three sons take over various
parts of the empire
and to make things even more confusing
they're all named
in some ways a variation after
constantine so there's constantine the
second
there's constans who's mentioned in the
tibetan sybil i believe it's him
and there's constantius the second
not the first that was constantine's
father constantius ii is the aryan
he kills off constantine the second and
he fights with constance
athanasius accuses constantius a second
and a couple of bishops around him
airing bishops
and he says concerning these two bishops
lusakis and violence
they dared to call
the emperor eternal while at the same
token
they belittle the son of god and call
him a creature so they continue to refer
to the emperor's eternal anyway
constance protects athanasius and he
even threatens to go to
war with constantius
over the protection of athanasius
because constantius wanted him dead
so is it this constantius uh
he's gotten a mixed uh the reception in
scholarship and again you've always got
to put the question mark up in relation
to the scholars because
you don't know what hermeneutical lens
they're using to interpret figures but
he was
according to the traditional sources the
ancient sources an orthodox king
who protected athanasius and he went
down in history that way
why i mention nothing else is he
dominates the literature in the fourth
century
sozumen's history socrates history
theodoran's history
written in the 400s they're all talking
about athanasius so
it could be him anyway this emperor's
reign is characterized
and now we're going back to the tibia
time sybil
um by great wealth and victory over the
foes of christianity
and end of paganism and the conversion
of the jews so
what we have here the antagonistic
forces
to let's say emergent christendom
in this context in the fourth century
are the uh pagans and jews
and that should not be interpreted
because people are quick to jump on the
um vilification bandwagon there was
uh conflict going on between these three
groups for centuries up until this point
you know
the first christians were jews and then
pagans were brought into that
the jews persecuted christians then
pagans persecuted christians so
don't read more into it i'm saying this
more for listeners
and viewers than what's there okay so uh
christianization of the empire is what
will happen and he will vanquish the
emperor will vanquish
gog and magog mentioned in ezekiel
richards spoke about them you both
i spoke about gog and magog the unclean
cannibalistic worse than the haredream
you know
uh driven by alexander the the great
beyond the gates of the north
he seals them in that later text the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius
um after defeating these unclean nations
uh the emperor goes to jerusalem puts
off his diadem from his head
lays aside his imperial garb and hands
over the empire of the christians to god
the father and to jesus christ
his son and this is still in the sybil
now this is it yourself
wow so it's all there right there in the
fourth century it's all right there in
the fourth century this anticipates
the apocalypse of pseudomethodius which
takes up all of these motifs
except um and you know it's the same
kind of trajectory with
uh the sybil you have constance
defeating um
the enemies of christianity and then um
uh later on the future emperor in pseudo
methodius and other texts defeats the
ishmaelites with the arabs
and then after that gog and magog appear
on the scene
um after defeating them or before facing
off against them
he defeats them he defeats gog and magog
um
[Music]
and then he goes and gives up his
scepter and his crown
um at golgotha dies
and then the antichrist comes and you
know the second coming happens just
after that
there are variations of this kind of
model and the antecedents are there in
the tibetan
uh civil um
the surprising thing is that a lot of
these motifs are going to appear again
with the final king of constantinople um
the eastern roman empire founded by
constantine
uh in thrace shores of the bosphorus we
spoke about it last time
and that's what we're going to move to
how are we going with time
uh jonathan i mean i'm fine to keep
going i think i think it's important so
i'm not a
we can just you can just we can just
continue if you if you're okay
i mean i would i would say we can maybe
kind of move
towards the towards the towards the the
different legends but i think this is
important to set the base
you know of where this kind of tradition
comes to
comes from let's say in terms of the the
the sybil
and also um but yeah so but we can
slowly kind of move towards also why why
there's a sense of this
this this emperor that is potent
in potential or sleeping why like if you
have a sense of why that is why that
happens
um and then maybe the difference because
there is a difference
between let's say the divine emperor and
the emperor that
that gives over his his his diadem to
christ you know that
it might seem uh for some people it
might seem like a
uh they may be cynical about it but in
terms of narrative
there is a difference between the cult
of the emperor and the emperor who
who ultimately gives up his power to
christ you know even in his own victory
yes you're right and in fact that's
something that i argue towards the end
of my book
that you know often the byzantines um
eastern christian romans and generally
christendom is accused of caesar's
papism but especially byzantium the fact
that the emperor was both
priest and king in the way that made him
kind of semi or quasi divine
um notwithstanding the fact that uh
paneer assists even up until justinian's
time
used that kind of rhetorical language
about the emperor
uh quasi divine language and um
and in spite of the fact that the
emperor would kind of represent himself
with a halo nevertheless
caesar a papism did not necessarily
apply because
the more suitable model in an
environment which is conditioned by
christ and his saints
through the church and its shepherds and
teachers the bishops
is the old testament model it's not the
pagan model
the pagan model dissipates and every
time you have an imposition of the state
because the state lapses into this
hubris
several times in byzantium the most
emphatic example
we just mentioned the aryan controversy
in relation to constantius ii but
later on the most emphatic example is
iconoclasm when they begin to break the
the icons
and they begin to the empress begin to
act in a way which
kind of gives the impression that they
are in charge of the church but
at that time god raises up he raises up
saints
shepherds of the church usually of
bishops but also monks and nuns and lay
heroes
to tell the emperor you know
take care of the world outside the
church and leave leave the church to its
shepherds and teachers
in fact the church is never under the
empire in byzantium
which is a mistake that many scholars
again make in relation to
assessments of this empire even when the
church
works with the state and constantine
initiates this when he
convokes the council of nicaea they are
working together but he's not presiding
at the council it's a bishop of the
church who's presiding
at the council saying oh she's of course
over so we need to make this very clear
that the church is one thing the state
is another when the state
in spite of its ostensible christianity
would
um exert itself against the church uh
uh impose heretical doctrines or behave
in a way which was scandalous
the church very often accused it of such
and castigated it
and um if it was persecuted then
subsequent
emperors would have to learn from the
disciples of the martyrs of the previous
generation
whose boss and this happened back and
forth
throughout the history of this empire
it's remarkable one of the reasons
why the empire is considered as falling
and again
things are nuanced and complicated it's
not just a matter of the empire
compromising at the end although it did
on an imperial level
have all this great spirituality we
spoke about it last time
one of the reasons why it's interpreted
as ending is because
of the imperial court's
questioning acceptance to come under the
roman catholic church of the time
in order to solicit imperial support and
he didn't listen to the church
so you know so we need we need to that's
the broader the broader let's say
framework but let's
let's delve into it then talk about the
sleeping king you're right the sleeping
king
who wakes up rouses off his drowsiness
and goes to fight the enemy let's say
clearing the path for the second coming
of christ
it's not um let's say doctrinal
eschatology
it's a variant it's it can even be a
dangerous one
but it's nothing like the divine kings
of the past he's a servant still this
king
irrespective of how good he might be but
where the motif of
him slumbering and waking up comes from
is actually from
the syriac pseudomethodius
um just to recapitulate uh it's
attributed to saint methodius of
olympus um in the syriac text or of
patara
in the greek text fourth century this
was a fourth century figure but
uh again this text was composed in the
seventh century
um after the um islamic conquest of
syria palestine and egypt so
you know it comes from a different
context um we saw with the tibetans uh
sybil that if it's constance that it's
talking about
there's a lot of socio-political um and
religious chaos in the fourth century um
we have the same circumstances happening
in the seventh century so these
prophecies arise
whenever civilization is destabilized
okay
and so um definitely that was fertile
ground
the 600s for the um rising up of this
particular kind of apocalyptic anxiety
um so the manuscript um
again it speaks about it's not the
history of the world so it's
part chronicle part apocalypse so
chronicles were at least in the
christian context initiated by
julius africanus the apologist and later
you see mrs caesarea
just tables and dates really of um the
reigns of kings
cross reference of the olympiads because
at that time at least before
the onicious exiguous came up with the
no domini
dating system and various other
chronographers and uh computational
thinkers let's say
came up with the anno mundi dating
system
it's reflected in this text to some
extent because it goes by
oh gosh more and more stuff is coming to
mind it goes
through uh the unfolding of
time from the creation of the world adam
and eve
through thousands of years leading to
the year
7000 right which
is modeled upon the recurrent week of
time
that we see in genesis and that we in
fact experience a seven day weekly cycle
the end of the seventh
uh the end of the six thousands of the
year
beginning the seven thousandth year
inaugurating that apocalyptic
time and this is known as millenarianism
that
year reign of christ with his saints and
there are many people in the middle ages
trying to figure out and in the dark
ages trying to figure out
whether or not christ comes before the
uh beginning of the 7000th year or just
after it when will antichrist come just
before the inauguration of the year 7000
or just after it
um or where did christ come
at the beginning of the year 6 000 and
does this represent the millennium up
until
the beginning of the year 7000 where
everything will end you know so
this um it can all get pretty messy
but it's the backdrop from a
chronological perspective to this text
and that factors in later on when we
talk about constantinople
so um this text goes for a history of
the world
and you've spoken about with richard
already you know the various important
junctures that it talks about talks
about
um again the rise of this
ishmael and you know again
many people would interpret this as you
know the muslims taking over christian
territory and they're seen
in a very antagonistic sense well they
are because people who are conquered are
seeing them this way and
sees pseudomethodius this way but the
reason why
these conquests happen is because of the
sins of the christian people
that's what he says that's also
reflected in later
uh resentions of this text in the
slavonic daniel it's called
which is written in the circumstances
the the arab conquest of sicily from the
byzantines so
again a different same yet different
kind of text
but the accusation is never against the
terrestrial enemies the act well
it's a description of what they do let's
say in times of conquest
but it's a uh reflexive
accusation that's meant to lead to
repentance it's because of the sins of
the christian people that these things
happen
right and you know that's that's there
in constantinople with the fall of the
city
in 1453 um
the first ecumenical patriarch after the
fall of the city uh
before he becomes patriarch he's still a
monk at the time he basically says you
know
uh romans you're losing your city
because uh instead of putting your faith
in god you put
your faith in the italians you know so
um
in terms of coming under roman
catholicism so there's all of that right
apocalyptic anxiety
um uh kind of introspection concerning
why these things might be happening
and um the references to after the
uh sleeping emperor rises and defeats um
the ishmaelites gog and magog and all of
that but
here is where the texas syriac text
describes
the sleeping emperor for the first time
this last roman emperor
will go forth and will be awakened or
aroused
against them that's the arabs like a man
who shakes off wine
one who plots against them as if they
were dead
so something about you know amidst the
sins of the christian
people he's um he's kind of like uh
neutralized until this shocks him into
action okay
yeah there's a sense in which like even
the idea of shaking off wine in the
sense of
being asleep not just being asleep uh
in terms of attention too in the sense
of being distracted being
being uh you know falling into
conflagration and being just
this this kind of uh dissipated king
let's say
that wakes up from from his drunkenness
so it's a it's it's it's a little
different from the idea of the marble
king but
it definitely those two images together
are very interesting if you
to actually kind of join them together
it's like fielding almost uh that's
where my mom yeah
exactly yeah very much like that image
of their man that's a good that's a
that's actually a good uh
in terms of the waking up from being
from being drunk or asleep in that sense
yeah that's a good image
that's that's uh that's right um but
that that actual description
this is strange because the author of uh
pseudonym authorities is not going back
to the book of revelation necessarily
because of the all of the anti-roman
imagery in that text right he's got to
look elsewhere
revelation is the backdrop to to some of
it of course but
this uh depiction of the sleeping king
actually appears originally in relation
to the lord to god
in the psalms and in psalm 78 verses 65
to 66 we read
then the lord awoke us from sleep as a
warrior wakes from the stupor of wine
he beat back his enemies he put them to
everlasting shame
it's basically transposing role that
belongs to god
to this last emperor of the romans the
lord waking up which is strange for us
to really
you know this very anthropomorphic way
of describing god waking up
yeah but you could also see it because
it says that it's the emperor that
shakes himself off like someone from
wine so you could see it as if it's god
waking him up
like he's the warrior being a being
awoke being woken up
in the psalms like it says in the psalms
that god will wake up the warriors and
so maybe it's the king
that is being made awake that is being
woken up by god
as someone who was drunk and kind of
dissipated let's say
well that's a reading of it definitely i
mean that's the way that they would have
read it i think
that the apocalypse you know god waking
up the sleeping king
but in the psalm it's it's a simile in
relation to
to god yeah i mean yeah it's an
interesting nuance but
the greek translation changes things a
bit which will
i mean tell me what you think of this so
the greek translation of pseudomythology
says
and i've taken this not from um this
version
uh the de martin oaks version translated
by benjamin garcia
i've taken it from paul j alexander's
translation in the byzantine apocalyptic
tradition
the greek translation of the text says
then there will suddenly arise against
them the ishmaelites with great fury and
emperor of the greeks or romans
he will awaken from his sleep like a man
who had drunk
wine up up to this point it's the same
but he's added great fury
okay who men considered like one dead
and utterly useless
in the previous texts they are the ones
with the enemies are the ones who are
dead
in this text it becomes reflexive
it's the king who was like one who was
dead and utterly
useless so i mean this
fits into the image that you were
drawing actually recently i i thought of
that when i was reading this
um and i can't wait to see how that uh
that ends up
but um another interesting motif that's
very important in the
apocalypse of pseudomethodist is
the connection between and this is more
richard's stuff but i just want to
mention it very briefly because it comes
up in later apocalypses
um okay alexander is the one who
uh chases the unclean nations uh to the
north and puts up a gate with a special
kind of a
material on it that actually has no
correspondence in reality whatever
magic whatever it is uh to keep them at
bay
right and then after that we read about
the marriage of
uh beezus and i didn't see the ethiopian
video yet
so i don't know did richard discuss uh
the marriage of business and
who said a little bit we're going to
talk about it more in the next one but
we we we mentioned a little bit how
uh the importance we of uh ethiopia
appears in
a byzantine apocalypticism right and
it's the place
where out of which let's say the the
emperor will the hidden emperor kind of
is
coming out of ethiopia let's say at the
end yeah
oh yeah i mean i'll touch upon it
briefly now because i don't want to kind
of uh
uh you know impose upon what comes up
next with
you and richard but the visas of course
is business of
mercado who founded byzantium uh the
greek polis later turned into
constantinople by constantine
husseth is the daughter of the ethiopian
king so greece and ethiopia are
connected
they have a daughter named byzantia who
is
married to rome to romulus amelos
and then romulus hameles gives her rome
as a dowry so that's
that's interesting because there's a
whole shift politically speaking
from the old rome to the new that's
manifested
in 381 with the second ecumenical
council that makes
new rome constantinople second to the
old rome in terms of the
um let's say that the taxes
the order of the ancient seas of
christendom and by the time you get to
the 500s in justinian's time that
becomes the pentaki
the five main seas of christendom rome
first among equals
later then constantinople alexandria
antioch jerusalem after the great schism
it becomes constantinople
alexandria antioch jerusalem so that
that's interesting i think
um and uh
then uh you know it follows the same
kind of trajectory that
uh the king of the romans after being
awakened defeats the ishmaelites
and then there's an invasion of the
unclean nations
who are the gog and magog defeated by
the king
and then he goes to golgotha
lays down his crown receptor dies
the cross goes up to heaven because it's
meant to go before christ when he comes
again
then you have uh the revelation of
antichrist the son of perdition which is
the way
saint paul refers to him um in
thessalonians
um once he appears and kills enoch in
elijah you have the second coming and
nothing is said about what happens after
the second coming
and that's basically the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius
uh following to some extent
the tibetan sybil um except it doesn't
give a name for the king
it it mentions in more detail based on
the psalms this notion of the king
being asleep and waking up being aroused
from drunkenness
um the greek text ads being uh as one
who was dead
and then he springs into action i
mentioned
earlier that later on um in the 9th
century we get a further reduction of
this
text but all of the chronic
chronographical and chronological
material
leading up to um
the rise of the last roman emperor is
omitted
it's all gone you get the same stuff
happening later
uh ishmael likes gog and magog goes to
jerusalem
gives up all world the authority
antichrist comes
and then the second coming happens but
um
instead of being given to methodius of
olympus or patara
this revelation is disclosed to the
prophet daniel by the archangel gabriel
and it's being written in the ninth
century um
it's been dated to around the early 800s
so the second wave of iconoclasm
has affected the byzantine
empire theophilus uh the emperor was
probably on the throne at the time and
iconoclast
and that's actually reflected within the
text because
the archangel gabriel says to the
prophet uh daniel
four beasts come out of the sea and
that's that's harkening back to daniel
and the first one is the isorian dynasty
which was the dynasty that initiated the
first wave of iconoclasm in the 700s
that's a beast so you see it's not just
a matter of criticizing
um the ishmaelites or those outside it's
also a matter of criticizing
uh the imperial court which had betrayed
the ordinances of god let's say the
tradition of the church
um in this case being the isorians
and and i think i think one of the
things that's important for people to
notice here also
is how the let's say the apocalyptic
motif
it really it's not only it's ultimately
not just talking about something like
this cosmic end of time but seems to be
brought back
and reused as a kind of pattern of
manifestation
which which appears in these moments of
difficulty
and so we could we can we can i think
that if we're
a little perceptive we can pull back
and notice how it's acting as a as a
kind of
a lattice or a narrative lattice to help
people
gauge and help people see how difficulty
happens and how we kind of come out
of difficulty like the image for example
of the
emperor which either falls into
drunkenness field in
theoden style right and and kind of is
uh is
is gone or goes into hiding and becomes
a hidden seed
aragon style aragorn style right so you
have these two images of the
of the lost king let's say one which is
fallen into dissipation
and one which is kind of this hidden
seed which you can't see yet but you
know that
at the final moment when it becomes
important the
the the sprout is going to come out and
going to to
to recapture the world let's say like
that's actually
a pattern of any moment that you break
down
right like any any breakdown that exists
in any society
or even at a personal level when you
fall into dissipation
but then your attention goes into hiding
let's say
and when when you come out of sin or
when you come out of
any kind of difficulty that you have
those
motifs will play out right
that they will play themselves out in
yourself and so i think
like i just want to kind of help people
see that the reason why we're talking
about this
does have a cosmic and historical aspect
but it also has a
even an aspect in yourself that you can
understand as a pattern of manifestation
of how things
fall down come back up fall down come
back up and keep happening all through
history
and there is a kind of cosmic version of
that so anyway so continue on
no no you just did a remarkable kind of
phillicalic
internalized reading of the text which
is which is fascinating because
in that time of crisis hope arises in
the form of this last roman emperor
let's say
and that can be interiorized perhaps
this is an externalization of something
as you mentioned that's being
experienced uh internally incrementally
and you know your your reading of it in
relation
to theater and aragorn i mean come on
this is how you interpret tolkien what
talking society
this is it you know where's richard um
yeah especially especially these days
with the whole this whole scandal around
the token society
it's like we need more we need more we
need more than the zodius
a little more pseudo-methodius than our
talking look 100
because this is existentially meaningful
whereas you know
anyway let's not go down that road um no
no that's that's uh really interesting
and i guess
uh the same kind of uh distress
and desire for renewal comes up again in
the west whenever this motif appears
because you don't you have in the
dark ages a lot of obsessive computation
to work out when
antichrist is going to return the
artists of modena
and um uh lotharius of saint armand and
others
and the years 500 and 800 are identified
as
uh the beginning of the year 6000
which some people were expecting to
inaugurate
um it's known as a millennialism so that
reign of christ with his saints leading
up until
uh the final judgment
but um of course this was shifted to the
year 1000 when dynasty six secrets came
up with the anno domini
system and you had a lot of expectation
but precisely because of the dark ages
because people were experiencing at
least on the continent
and i know that they've been exaggerated
the dark ages my my brother reminds me
of this a lot actually because
um he's uh uh his field of research
is um celtic and welsh geography around
around this period and so because you
know the church was there in the west
i'm like of course i
know you know but at the same time on
the continent
you had the dark ages so um that's not
withstanding gregory the theologist and
all these other great figures
uh but definitely because of this
experience of a devastation lack of
civilization brought upon by the
visigoths and the vandals and those who
destroyed
the western roman empire throughout the
400s
they actually want christ to return
imminently
to alleviate them of their suffering but
that's problematic
because christ himself says and perhaps
is a good juncture to bring this into it
concerning
the last things what we call the
apocalypse or the eschaton or the second
coming he says in matthew
no one knows the day or the hour not
even the son but only the father
so if he himself says that
then why is it that you know we
obsess about when he will come back to
transform the cosmos
universally when he can be experienced
at each and every divine liturgy
and the saints already experienced him
in anticipation of that final
resurrection so
if we have confidence in the church look
ultimately if we have confidence in the
church this
there's no need for these but that being
said i've never been through
um a famine or uh you know
uh the collapse of society so i don't
know how i'll react you know i'll
probably be running in the first to uh
to write a you know scribble on
something you know he'll be back
you know next week at a certain time of
the day because i want it all to end the
misery at the end but
that's that's basically where all of
this um uh what gives rise to this uh
desperate uh hope for it to be
pinpointed
it's a hope but it's a beautiful hope
that one day he will come
we expect that he will come but there's
a desperation behind trying to calculate
when and how
and where and in what circumstances
because he himself does not disclose
that
so you know getting back to the slavonic
daniel
again written in palermo oh sorry yes
sorry i'm i'm muted that's why let me
just bring in one image
i think um in terms of
because one of the things we're showing
like we're talking about this idea
this image of uh of an emperor let's say
that
is bringing back order in christ's name
you know and but there's also this image
of antichrist which is
there right in revelation and which
strangely comes right after or right
before you're not sure
so it's very disturbing because you have
an image of a worldly
power which is which is supposedly
restoring order in the name of christ
and then you have an image of a worldly
power
which is taking power and in storing a
kind of order
in an anti-christian way and so it's
like
which one is it and it's not that simple
because you have a sense in which
antichrist is
parodying christ and that even the even
the
you know even the faithful can be
deceived so it's like how do we
recognize the difference
between christ between let's say a holy
emperor
an antichrist between the holiness
something which would which would be
kind of a holy order
and an antichrist and uh
anyways the way that i see it because it
seems like even in the imagery of rome
that you see in revelation you have
a sense in which i've talked about this
in my q a recently where
there's an image of the beast and the
prostitute
right and and it said and a prostitute
is basically a place where all the
nations trade right where all the
there's this confusion of identity where
all the wasted seed goes
into this this one place let's say so it
becomes like a place of mixture of
confusion and all of that
but that's what that's what a prostitute
is then you have this image of the new
jerusalem and it says in
the image of the new jerusalem that the
glories of all the nations will be
gathered into the city
so what's the difference between a
prostitute where all the
wasted stuff goes into and then a city
where all the glory gets gathered into
one
place and so it seems like that's the
mystery or that's the difference
and and one of them like in the image of
alexander for example like
the good version of alexander where
alexander rises up
you know with his griffins and then
reaches up to
he comes close to the prime mobile then
here's a voice which tells alexander
enough go back like you've you you've
gone high enough you can't go higher
than this
and then go go back down like it seems
like there's a key in there
that there there's a sense in which
the emperor that gives his diadem up to
christ
indeed in the difference of the emperor
or the the ruler
who wants to gather all authority to
himself and wants to be
to act as a god in the world now how
what does that look like in practical
terms
it's because sometimes you could you
could imagine an emperor pretending
let's say or or politically using that
that image of himself you know because
i'm thinking about let's say even what's
going on in russia let's say
division of putin for example so there's
a cynical vision of putin
which is that putin is using the church
to
to reach his political goal and there's
a less cynical version of putin which is
putin is genuinely wanting to
incorporate christian value and
christian let's say
rule in russia so it's like is it both
is it one is it the other it's hard to
discern that
it's it's hard to discern that but i
think in relation to the church and
this goes not just for the circumstances
that you mentioned in russia but
throughout
orthodox countries and uh extending back
to the byzantine period
the church is meant to witness to christ
in the world for the salvation of the
world it is
beyond the world we have no lasting city
here but our citizenship is in heaven
that's both in the epistle to diagnose
us and harkens back to st
paul um nevertheless within this world
there has to be an engagement with it
and that can take a
political artistic philosophical
literary whatever means in order to
accomplish
this drawing of people to christ i think
when one sees
and let's say an explicit testimony to
christ
in the world that draws people within
the within
or into the sacred space of the church
to participate
in its rhythms and the sacraments
because the church is the body of christ
then that's a good thing even if if
someone is doing it cynically
and it leads to that outcome god brings
about that outcome that is still a good
thing
and we that kind of harkens back to what
we were talking about
in relation to the martyrs from a
certain point of view it's horrible
because our massacre from another point
of view they become
intercessors to christ for each and
every one of us and they reign with him
forever and ever so
from their point of view saint euphemia
actually said this to saint paecios
because she appeared to him what 30 40
how long ago 50 years ago she appeared
to him after he was in treating her
do you know the story so he had been
entreating
saint euphemia um because he wanted to
know
how it was that she solved the impasse
in relation to the fourth ecumenical
council
in relation to the
condemnation of mere physicism or
monophysitism
that christ only has one nature which
would have substituted
his human nature now in the council of
chelsea and in 451 the church
uh affirmed that christ has two natures
he is fully divine and fully human
um in one person in the office
in one person in two natures
in the office he means in two natures
divine and uh and human
uh as uh he's fully god and in that way
he's able to save us from death and he's
fully human so that we might participate
in his
victory over death she wasn't fully
human we couldn't participate in anyway
saint fema performed a miracle um he had
been praying to her
he heard a knock on his door in the door
of his cell
um he ignored it because there was no
one else around and then he turned
around and he saw her standing inside
his cell
and in order to test her he asked her to
venerate the trinity with him
and she did that and then in the course
of their conversation he asked her how
did you enjoy your martyrdom and she
said to him something like
if i knew all the glories that came
afterwards i would have allowed that
martyrdom to last a lifetime or
something
this is a communique let's say from a
third century saint because she died
during diocletian's
persecution to a modern saint uh so
you know bad circumstances good and
again
if the circumstances uh
initiated by a ruler uh lead to
participation in the life of the church
ultimately that's a good thing that's
whether you're talking about constantine
or anybody else
there's a cynicism in relation to that
that comes up again and again
um especially when people are let's say
preoccupied
with the sins of a particular people or
or group um in the world
um you know there are there are certain
junctures at which the church cannot
compromise not trying to in relation
to morals and it should prophetically
castigate the world when it
behaves in an evil manner uh but
ultimately if
people come to the church to venerate
the icons and to be conditioned by the
life of the church if it leads to their
undertaking uh introspection and
repentance
and and all of the things that we
experience as orthodox christians
then that's a good isn't it that's my
only answer i i don't know if i if we
can dwell upon that uh
no i think i think so i think so i think
what fascinates me
like in terms of the image of let's say
the sleeping emperor
and this idea of a return of an emperor
which will serve christ
as it's collated like that is right next
to the image of antichrist or
a kind of antichrist vision of an
emperor
to me there's something to me there's
something in this duality which
fascinates me
which sometimes i wonder if it has
something
to do with the very ambiguity of rome
itself in the history of christianity
or the idea that rome is both the beast
the [ __ ]
but also then the conversion of rome
ends up being an image of the new
jerusalem
whether or not there's a sense in which
like when christ talks about how the
wheat and the tares are growing together
right where that there's something of
that where there's something of
civilization
which becomes a vehicle for the glory of
god
but nonetheless contains in itself
always the problematic
problematic aspect of the lineage of
cain let's say right the dark aspect of
civilization
that those two kind of continue on until
the eschaton to exist
together until they're finally solved in
a cosmic way
i'm not sure it helps in terms of
practical i'm not sure it helps in terms
of sometimes
knowing what to do in in a practical
sense but i think that at least
conceptually it helps me to understand
why these images seem to
always kind of be next to each other
let's say in
in in the imagination of people yeah the
the
uh rome is multivalent in other words
civilized i mean
saint augustine might uh anticipate the
the difficulty because he says something
like this
in his city of god the church is in the
world and the world is in the church and
they will be intertwined until the
eschaton which is the wheat in the tears
example being interpreted there so how
this uh
relates in a spiritual sense to the
to the christ antichrist dialectic let's
say
and how that's transposed
civilizationally
well the church is always above each and
every respective culture
and civilization because it is
ultimately christ's transcendent kingdom
which takes on
the forms and modes and morality
modalities of uh
the world to a degree you know we enter
physical buildings that are built by
people
icons are painted by people but god's
providence is always
active there and through tradition
passes down
the holy spirit passes down the way
things are done in the church in a very
secure manner from generation to
generation
so the church is one thing it engages
with the world constantly
but the world is another thing and the
church can take the good from the world
and interpret it in a positive way and
use it but it also has to reject the bad
in the world
and even prophetically denounce it and
that's a complicated thing that i think
can only be judged
as you mentioned on a case-by-case
scenario by those who have discernment
namely the saints and i'm not one of
them so i don't know
i mean you know but yeah
at least it's a call for us to stay
vigilant in terms of
to kind of have us a certain vigilance
and also it's almost like
there's a sense in which sometimes we're
overly cynical
of of the the of the reality of the
state or the reality of how
christ can manifest themselves through
through authority
and then sometimes we're overly
enthusiastic about
that right and so it seems like those
two people seem to slip into those
two extremes constantly in the history
of christianity
and that ultimately what we would need
is more is a a kind of balanced vision
where we are capable of
seeing christ the fruits of christ in
manifest themselves through authority
but also
be cynical enough to not be to not
confuse the emperor and christ himself
let's say something like that
or not confuse the state with god and
god himself look i agree with that i
think you've nuanced it there because
you know it's like
be enthusiastic about christ but know
that in the worldly circumstances you
know he might permit certain
circumstances to be that way for a
reason
and what we might perceive as good might
be genuinely
genuinely good and intended as good or
it might be bad
but he might bring it about to a good
that we don't know about yet
so it's good to almost even you need
discernment and that's hard
that that's what the saints have like i
can't
i can't even begin to to understand uh
what they see in worldly circumstance
where they say for instance
uh you know something that looks
terrible just wait and you'll see
how it'll turn out down the track you
know that's um that's a
charism i think that that the saints are
endowed with um
in relation to the final emperor uh
motif
and and it's it is a a deviation
it's not eschatology which is you know
the uh
the way that we formally define the
study of the end times from
which in greek is a plural noun meaning
the last things um
it's not the last emperor motif is
relegated to a subdivision we don't
expect this christians a final emperor
to come
we don't we we expect the king to return
the lord jesus christ
but you know in times of distress this
motif appeared again and again
and there was perhaps nothing more
distressing than the fall of the city of
constantinople the queen of cities
so do you want to jump to uh constantine
paleologos i think so i think
like we've been going for almost two
hours so maybe we can go to constantine
and then and then and call it call it
after that so maybe
talk a little bit about about this kind
of final image that appears at the fall
concentrate poland
and we'll yeah okay um
jonathan uh well there's a lot to say i
know sorry there's a lot to say
so you know because it goes back to
let's say um
the circumstances that are conditioning
the empire from the 1200s you know
after the uh constantinople is sacked by
the crusaders in 1204
three uh kingdoms spring up in uh nicaea
in
emperors and in trebezond of those three
it's the empire of nicaea that makes it
back into constantinople
and initiates the paleololos dynasty
which rules until the fall of the city
in 1453.
before that during the the empire of
nicaea within the empire of nicaea which
is in asia minor
just before the last great dynasty there
was an emperor called saint
john vartazis and saint john vartazis
who was known as saint john the merciful
he's the saint in the church
he's after the city was reconquered in
1261 by the byzantines it was uh
the michael paleoloros after the
laskorids
who went in there and took the city the
relics of saint john vatachis were taken
into the city the incorrupt body of the
saint and it was believed that he was
sleeping
um and that one day after
the fall of the city that he would also
wake up
to reconquer the city so the the motif
of the
fall of the sleeping emperor appears uh
also in relation to this king
but it's crystallized with constantine
paleologus now constantine palullos was
dealt a pretty
uh poor hand in relation to uh you know
when he was born in other circumstances
maybe he would have done wonders because
he was a
brilliant tactician a great leader um
his his
older brother was john the eighth
paleologos
uh who in 1438-39 went over to ferrara
florence to broke up
the union with the roman catholic church
which was militant at the time as we
know and
this was done in order to bring back
support for the byzantines who had now
been encompassed
by this stage by the ottomans the
ottomans had taken thrace
murad ii the father of mehmed ii who
conquered constantinople
in 1421 um he took
um idirni adrianopol which he renamed it
didn't he which is in the race and made
that his capital so
a stone's throw away from constantinople
so it was surrounded all that was left
to the empire was
the city itself and the peloponnese
in greece in southern greece the more
and constantine in fact kicks off his
career in the moria
in the peloponnese he becomes the despot
of mistra
which is nisbata and it is there within
that framework which was
a place of letters of veridition the
seeds of the renaissance were there
that he um first sean as a leader
and in the
[Music]
14 early 14 1440s so after the
failed reunion council ferrara florence
because when john the eighth came back
saint mark of ephesus refused to sign
the
the documents of the council refused to
accept it because it was a
unilateral imposition of roman catholic
doctrine
which considered heretical onto the
orthodox church without discussion
without
so the people rejected it uh and that
caused a lot of tension in the city
which plays out up until the fall of the
city
plays out up until the fall of the city
constantine then
um you know he
he doesn't make uh his uh let's say
view of the union of ferrara florence uh
known
he gives a lot of time to the
anti-unionists which prompted a later
historian to say that he was only
pretending to go go along with it
what's interesting is this um they did
manage to get
the initiative for another crusade uh
comprised of poles transylvanians and
burgundians
to attack the ottomans as that crusade
was moving through eastern europe
constantine as the despot of the
peloponnese
in misra takes his chance
to extend the boundaries of misra into
mainland greece
and to take back little principalities
that
since the fourth crusade belonged to the
italians but there was a prophecy
in relation to the
border between the peloponnese
and attica in corinth
separating the gulf of current from mid
and northern mainland greece
is a six mile wall known as the
hexamelion and there was a prophecy that
said
that this six mile world hexamillion
would be built
four times and the fourth and final time
that it would be built it would
last forever you know the first time was
during xerxes the second time
uh you know the battle of the persians
in ancient times second time was during
justinian's reign it was rebuilt then
the third time was during um uh
constantine's father
manuel paliologos he rebuilt it but each
time it was demolished
constantine rebuilt it in the 1440s and
that was seen as a fulfillment of a
prophecy that's his first foray into
prophecy
and then he extended himself beyond the
moreau when the ottoman sultan murad
after he defeated that fourth crusade
and discovered what constantine was
was doing he came back smashed the
hexamelion and basically undid all of
his work it was very tragic
uh constantine was appointed emperor
after
john the eighth died and basically had
to oversee
um uh you know the empire in times when
uh which would lead to the ultimate
conquest of the city in 1453 on may 29th
let's jump to the final months of the
city
because that's when we get a lot of
apocalyptic imagery emerging
so um
[Music]
there is a desire on the part of
constantine to get western help
so he um actually performs he allows for
the performance of a union liturgy
catholics and orthodox together
in a sophia in the cathedral church
believing that that will
well that was the term set upon them by
rome that if they showed that they had
accepted the union between the roman
catholic church and the orthodox church
that they would send over a crusade
what they did get was a former byzantine
um what was
a visiting a bishop who became a roman
catholic carbon with the council ferrara
florence isidore of kiev
rock up with 300 archers for constantine
at the time was better than nothing
further help does arrive from the west
not in the form of the crusade a
mercenary named
justiniani longo the genoese mercenary
justiniani
giovanni justiniani longa arrives with
700 soldiers so that encourages the
emperor even more
all the while the correspondence with
mechmet ii who wants to take the city
is floundering um and we don't have to
go into the reasons why that's the case
in the spring of 1453
mcmet's forces between 60 and 80
thousand strong marched from ebitda
towards constantinople and on april the
11th the ottomans attacked the city
walls with cannon fire
in mid-april an attack on the landwood
wars was thwarted by the romans in the
genoese working concert compelling
mcmahon to turn to a naval strategy
and that's when if you imagine
constantinople as a peninsula
um a promontory surrounded by three
sides of water with land wood walls on
its western side
they got the ottoman ships which were in
the bosphorus
across the northern
tip uh across the uh the golden horn
from constantinople there was a
piece of land known as pera or galata
they managed to get
70 vessels over land and put them into
the golden horn which was
just off the northwood walls of the city
and that happened uh around the 18th
of april to the 22nd of april
so beginning of the end let's say for
the city
uh on the 16th of may on the landwood
side of the city
sappers were creating underground
trenches to reach the outer walls
and these were discovered and destroyed
by the byzantines and on the 19th of may
a turkish
siege tower was repelled
and then there are the portents now
i don't know what to make we have to
might have to discuss these because
these are very interesting on the 22nd
of may
the moon was eclipsed and on the
following day at
midday on the 23rd the icon of the
mother of god
she who leads the way was processed
around the city for the lattice
protection
but a terrible thunderstorm broke out
and the icon slipped
and fell from the frame on which it was
mounted and the procession was then
immediately abandoned in fact the
sources say that they couldn't
lift the icon up that an invisible force
was keeping it
pressed to the ground on the 24th of may
that's the next day after the procession
this city was enveloped by a thick fog
until the evening
when a red glow was seen on the dome of
aya sofia
the main cathedral of the city we've
discussed it before
uh and a glow this glow rose to the peak
of the dome of the sofia and disappeared
and this is recorded in both the
byzantine and ottoman sources
what do we make of this i mean what do i
make of what importance
in general or of those importance in
particular importance of these potency i
mean they're pretty
they're pretty they're pretty obvious i
don't see
like the idea of the of the sky becoming
red or the moon becoming red or
the idea that this is related to death
somehow um
you know you hear that in lord of the
rings once again where it says you know
the sky is red
means that blood was shed today or
whatever uh i mean i think that
these porns are are very intuitive you
know the idea of the icon that falls and
cannot be cannot cannot uh be lifted
you know it's not a it's not that um
there's nothing mysterious about the
importance in terms of what they of what
they
signify you know we saw there have been
recent importance like that that have
been pretty
astounding if you think of for example
pope francis
trying to release two doves for the
peace between russia
and ukraine and then one dove and both
dove being attacked
in in the sky by a black bird and a
white bird
you can see you can find their pictures
of it there he releases these two doves
by a young girl and a young boy dressed
in blue and red it's almost like this
image
and in the release of the doves and then
one bird gets attacked like a crow
and then the other bird the other dove
gets attacked by like a seagull
and uh and and it's like yeah there's
not gonna be peace between russia and
ukraine it's like
it's one of those it's one of those
things important happened i don't know
what to say it happened
this is the thing this is the thing uh
because you know while i
i ask you uh to provoke conversation you
know i'm not
trying to put you on the spot but yeah
because
while of course i don't believe in
the myth or the legend of the final
roman emperor
i believe everything that we've
discussed about christ um and the saints
but
you know uh here i have no trouble
accepting these importance
because this city was so inundated by
relics the presence of holy figures we
know that
you know what if there were unnamed
saints in the city and this
is what we know happens in such
circumstances when
god's uh beloved um under threat
uh it happened in relation to saint john
chrysostom when saint john chrysostom
was
exiled from constantinople on two
occasions the first time an earthquake
um
occurred during his first exile during
the second exile
aliadoxia again rule occult stuff but in
relation to
the the female empress she died
and i think the the cable church
mysteriously was set ablaze
so you know these things happened in
relation to to constantinople and
um the fact that uh these signs were
corroborated by both sides
that's that's very interesting anyway um
and on the 28th of may so after the
portence
um uh and again you know you can
understand this given the
what was taking place uh uh everybody
gathered in
sofia and um put aside their differences
and um
they they celebrated the liturgy
together and when
um when constantine communed and asked
forgiveness
for his sins from the people and left to
do a final inspection of the walls a
terrible moaning and wailing was heard
a very very moving stuff when you read
the accounts
the final siege began on may 29th at 1
30 a.m
um there were three waves of attacks on
the landwood walls
with cannon fire as well the turkish
cannon bombardment began at the saint
romanos gate
which is basically in the middle of the
landwood walls
you can find a gate against a a map of
constantinople and you will see
in any good map where the saint romanos
gate is um
the sultan sends his irregular troops to
attack the land with walls but they were
cut down by the byzantines
and after two and a half hours of
slaughter met calls them back
at 4am a second wave of troops and
anatolian army
many of whom were former christians were
attacked and also repelled
and at 5am the third wave janice series
made up of former christian uh
boys converted to islam these with the
janissaries
uh and trained as the sultan's elite
guard was sent to attack and these were
the basically the hard hitters
the emperor constantine led the defense
which seemed to be holding ground
at this point one of two things
happens one before the other there is at
towards the north of the landwood walls
a gate
known as the circus gate where
some of the german soldiers under
giovanni longo the bukiardi brothers
were undertaking skirmishes
of the walls and back in and they had
forgotten to close the door
so uh some of the ottoman soldiers uh
rushed in
and were able to put up flags on the
ramparts
at the um at the northern side of the
theodosian walls
at around the same time uh justinial
justiniani longo who's fighting with
constantine uh
around the saint romanus gate uh he's
he's mortally wounded and it's
he's been wounded a few times these
people were fighting uh sleeplessly for
days
uh and he he asks constantine for the
keys to the gate behind them because
it's a three-tiered wall
theodosian walls um so that he can go
back into the city
in order to get mended and constantine
gives him the keys
and his soldiers the genoese they take
him away but then other genoese were
there
think that he's retreating right think
that their people are retreating
so they leave and they leave the romans
alone uh
to fight at this spot on the saint
romanos gate
and here the accounts vary we don't know
what happened to constantine paleologus
um some people say that he threw off his
regalia
at this point this moment knowing that
all was lost and threw himself into the
fray
others say that he was trampled um by
the
on rush of ottoman soldiers um
some say that he uh you know had a few
um
jewels with some ottoman soldiers and uh
was uh
killed in that way that he was
decapitated
uh during uh during the
jewel or that his body was discovered
afterwards and decapitated
or that he was buried um in a mass grave
and the way that people identified him
one or two people identified him was
because they saw the purple
boots of the roman emperor would wear we
don't know
what the reality is here and they don't
have there is
people don't have his body no yeah
his body does even though um uh
there were many uh people who believed
that he was buried in various places so
some people later on said that he was
buried
in the gul jamir which was once the
church of saint theodosia
which the feast day of which is the 29th
of may so
it's one of the late ecumenical
patriarchs who
refers to the belief so not necessarily
that he himself believed it but the
belief is in the 1800s
that constantine is buried in
the because there were certain turks and
romans would go there greeks would go
there and uh
and uh venerate his tomb
um there was the uh
there's a belief that uh he a small
non-descript
grave in one of the regions in istanbul
is described as being his grave
uh as believed as being his grave again
so the people who are writing about it
they don't actually believe it by edwin
uh augustus grosvenor who was a
american uh historian and uh
tutor in constantinople for a while
right now i think he was a pastor in one
of the protestant churches
and while he was tuning in
constantinople uh in the 1800s he would
see
greeks going to a a grave in a district
known as
um where is it
in constantinople and
this was put to an end by the ottoman
authorities and he himself says in the
description that this was not his grave
uh the turkish accounts all have him uh
let's say
uh being um presented in one way or
another to the sultan like he's
been decapitated his head taken to the
assault on something after his death
but we don't know the legend quickly
arose however that
um he's not dead that he was plucked
from the spot by an angel and taken to
the golden gate but he was put in the
subterranean cave
um this is the subterranean cave is
important in terms of the seed that i
talked about before
the idea of the the emperor's ship
moving down
into a seed form where the king vanishes
uh but like like i said vanishes in
invisibility
but then but then is hidden in the earth
like a treasure or a seed that it will
sprout again later
but yeah that that's that's analogous in
terms of the symbolism that's right
i mean um and this this image emerges
within the next century in laments that
are written about constantinople
and the final king so these laments uh
form part of the popular folklore and um
and literature but there's a few
interesting things that are recounted
about him
in relation to uh they look exactly like
some of the motifs that we discussed
earlier just to bring everything full
circle in relation
to the tibetan cereal pseudomonas
methodius
and the slavonic daniel it's called the
sylvanic daniel i didn't mention it
before because
that rendition of the pseudomethodius
with uh
which is transferred to daniel the
prophet
only exists in a slavonic version that's
why it's called the saronic daniel but
um there's this one lament that talks
about constantine
just before the city falling seeing
um a queen entering a church of the
virgin now constantinople was considered
protected by the virgin mary
the invincible champion from around the
7th century onwards and he follows her
into the church and she sat on a
bishop's throne and looked very mournful
then she opened her holy mouth and
addressed the emperor
this unhappy city was dedicated to me
and many a time i have saved it from
wrath
now too i have entreated my son and my
god but alas he has decreed that this
time you should be consigned to the
hands of your enemies
because the sins of your people see it's
the same kind of
reflexive and uh introspective way of
viewing things blaming oneself for the
calamity instead of
one's external enemies which is the
christian thing to do
we're meant to love our neighbors so
we're meant to love the turk and the
italian and
the roman catholic and everyone else so
i say that to mitigate any possible
objective that will
might come up in the comments you know
it just happens um
so i've been treated my son my god but
last year's decree this time you should
be inside the hands of your enemies
because the sins of your people have
inflamed the anger of god so leave your
imperial crown
here for me this like fourteen hundreds
fifteen hundreds
seven hundred years after slavonic
daniel you know and it's come up again
in the byzantine context leave your
crown here for me
to look after until such a time as god
will permit another to come and take it
when the emperor heard this he became
very sad he took his crown
and scepter left by the last roman king
who was asleep and woke up after his
defeat of gog and magog
and the ishmaelites at the foot of gold
arthur he leaves his crown inceptor
at the feet of the virgin i know it lays
them on the altar sorry and he stood in
tears and said
my lady since for my sins i've been
bereft of my imperial majesty i resign
also my soul into your hands along with
my crown
so he's relinquishing his life to her
the way that the last roman emperor
would relinquish his
life at golgotha in the previous texts
um the lady of the angels replied may
the lord god rest your soul in peace in
the company of these saints
the emperor made obeisance and went to
kiss her knee and she vanished and her
eunuchs who are angels
vanished with her but neither the crown
nor the scepter were found where they
had been left
for the lady the mother of god took them
with her to keep until such a time as
there would be mercy for the wretched
race
of christians how epic is that
yeah definitely that's amazing that
brings it all together and you know
uh what's very interesting donald m
nichol who translated the text
that i just read to you uh he goes okay
so that was in this book the immortal
emperor which is
the book on the legends of the last uh
king of the romans constantine palullos
the lady he says takes the crown and the
acceptable of his sword
what a constantine by the law of
lululus's sword well a 19th century
italian ambassador to constantinople
named tekko
claimed to have it in his private
collection of arms
and to have taken it from the tomb of
macmitt ii in 1866 a delegation
of the greek or roman the romney
community from constantinople
presented a ceremonial sword to the
danish prince constantine
heir to the throne of the helenes
because the greeks were ruled by
german-laded kings from denmark
you know and uh on the occasion of his
coming of age
claiming that it had belonged to
constantine the eleventh value laws
they even referred to this new
constantine as constantine the twelve
so this had um a long i never heard
any of that that's that's mad it's all
in here
actually when the new greek state was
founded after the um
uh the hellenic independence in 1821 in
the 1800s and it's the 200 year
anniversary of that this year
so that's um that's also very
interesting because the modern greek
nation
um was founded uh uh
by people who you know cannot saints
heroes but they were they were very much
interested in the celebration of
orthodoxy publicly and so that's all
very interesting but
you know they went looking according to
a reference in this book
um they went looking for an heir i don't
know who went looking some of the
representatives of the newly formed
government for an heir
of constantly by laws in the west but
couldn't find one and there were many
people who claimed to be heirs in the
west
and in the east when there's a whole
trajectory outlined in this book
but i think that's very interesting
concerning the sword
uh and concerning um uh uh
the kind of afterlife of this uh belief
in the final king
which we saw was popularized in the folk
songs that we mentioned at the beginning
of
of uh our talk um uh
you will come like lightning and that's
actually very
in that particular song which is a
beautiful song and i can send you the
links maybe you can put them
for people to listen to he conflates
imagery that's associated with christ
with the emperor so you will come like
lightning you know
um uh you will bring light and all these
sorts of things it's just uh
it's very interesting um uh do we have
time for i think i sorry if we have time
for what
for one more reflection here let's have
one more reflection all right go for it
okay thanks sorry we've gone for such a
long time it's really fascinating stuff
but so but yeah go for it
it is thanks jonathan thank you for your
your patience for this um the historian
ducas relates the following in relation
to constantine's column
and this again harkens back to the
apocalyptic literature from earlier
centuries because the slavonic daniel
speaks about the last emperor yes he's
aroused from sleep and everything else
well not right from sleep he is
discovered sorry
through divine revelation divine
revelation discloses him in the slavonic
daniel in the text written in
the 800s in in sicily so he wasn't
sleeping
but he's poor he's like a pauper king
now dukkha says the following concerning
the fall of constantinople
um when the turks broke in this is a
historian writing in the 1400s
the christians rushed to aya sophia the
great church and
that's what happened monks and nuns men
and women carrying their babies and
abandoning their homes
the street was packed with people making
for the church
the reason for their stampede was this
there was an ancient and false prophecy
that the city was destined to be
violently captured by the turks
who would slaughter the christians as
far as the column of constantine
this brings it back to our talk from
last time the column
uh the from the point from which
constantine began construction on his
city as we saw
at that point however an angel bearing a
sword would come down
and hand over the sword to an unknown
man a very plain and poor man standing
beside the column
the angel would say to him take this
sword and avenge the lord's people
that's this pauper king manifesting now
from the 9th century transposed into the
1400s so this literature was alive and
well in concert
that's amazing because that's so close
to the image of arthur
who takes the sword from the stone
without knowing what's going on and
nobody knows
and he brings the sword anybody's like
what what what does this child
have the sword and he's he's revealing
secretly that he is the the future king
yeah that's right the symbol of the
power and might of the sword well this
is something that
of course it bifurcates it kind of goes
east and west like this you know yeah
yeah i mean that's another topic in
itself and so so this popper who
receives the sword next to the
ends up being the hidden emperor let's
say
uh that's the implication because he
will then chase them
to monodendrion which is where the red
apple tree was which we talked about the
beginning of the talk
um either at the borderlands between
byzantium and
uh the ottoman empire or where the turks
came from or the arabs depending on when
you
which text and when it was written um so
yeah that's that's then the new final
emperor let's say
um this poor picking so you know they
had a long lifespan these uh
these uh myths and legends of the final
well thank you so much i think that
maybe i want to add one last thing
before we end it's mostly for people to
to be able to pull back from all these
stories and to
on the one hand understand that we don't
always have we don't have to see
these stories these tropes these
patterns as
happening explicitly in the way that
some people might expect them
to happen or not happen but we need to
be able to understand them
as valuable even in their most
even in the most folkloric way that they
appear
we need to be able to understand them as
valuable as manifesting patterns of
how things happen and the way in which
they are captured mythologically
and in legends can help us nonetheless
have insight on how things go away and
how they come back how they come back
for example the image of the idea that
hidden in a popper
is the king it's something you see in
fairy tales all the time that you have
this
imagery of the golden ball which falls
to the bottom of the the pond or
all these imagery of a value being
hidden in the field and then being
being found by in a surprising way
you know hidden in something and so all
of these images can help us
understand how reality works even if we
we have to be careful
not to become not to become too enamored
by them
so that we start to to to become
obsessed and because you see that right
you see people become obsessed
and start to see like what the science
and the science and the science
the world will manifest itself in
science and we will see the signs of the
time but we have to be careful
not to become too literal in the in the
bad sense
and and remember for example i keep
wanting to remind people that when it
says in the old testament that elijah
will return
before will come before the messiah that
that elijah
was john the baptist and that really is
how that pattern
ended up manifesting itself now for a
literalist at the time
it would have been very frustrating for
them to hear christ say well yeah elijah
did come it's john the baptist
and it would have been very frustrating
for them to see that but for someone
who's able to kind of pull back and
understand these as these kind of the
way in which the world kind of lays
itself out in these patterns
uh it becomes it becomes at once less
dangerous
and more insightful for you to be able
to see
how it is that reality unfolds so so
that's my last i don't know if there's a
last thing you want to say on top of
that
i think i agree with everything you just
said and you know the um the stories
themselves are tragic too and they give
some sense of hope to people who were
suffering i mean
this is um what we see unfolding in each
of those contexts and you know this
you know it's these these stories
because they gave comfort to subdued and
subjugated people
uh in the 7th century
in the 9th century and in the 15th
century they're benign more or less
unless we become
literalistic and uh you know preoccupied
with them to avenge ourselves on aries
we're meant to love our neighbor love
our enemies
in imitation of christ and we can take
the good from these stories
as well so you know you've got even
deeper by saying that you know the
expected outcome might
not be uh in the literal sense you know
the final king or of the antichrist or
how or whatever motif that we touched
upon tonight it might come in a way that
we don't expect
and that's a very deep way of reflecting
upon that and i appreciate that
um
the symmetry is interesting this is a
last just because i forgot to mention it
some of the writers uh around the uh
this period they say two things they say
that uh the city itself
uh its fall actually saved orthodoxy
because of the fact that um the imperial
court that had gone under rome
dissipated and the paradoxical
putting of all of the orthodox nations
under the
ecumenical patriarchate uh which was
considered a um
a millet a kind of like a ethnaki
uh that had contained within itself all
of those people that ascribe to the same
religion
through which the patriarch would be
responsible to the sultan and vice versa
that providentially preserved orthodoxy
because the serbs and the bulgarians
also were going over
who attempted to go over previous
centuries to catholicism to get military
help
so that's this that aspect but the fall
of the city had a positive outcome
for the church there's another aspect
that there's a symmetry
between the founding of constantinople
and its fall in terms of the fact it was
founded by constantine
who had a mother named helen and it fell
with the constantine whose mother was
named
helen she changed her name to ibomoni
when she became a monk saint pomoni
but that symmetry is eerily mirrored by
the old rome which was founded by
romulus
and ended with romulus or costales so
there's a pattern there that was made
manifested twice and that confirms i
think
uh what you just said jonathan yeah
all right everybody well thank you for
your attention and i hope this will be
this is food for a thought and you know
we'll put in the resources more
resources obviously
in the links for people to look into
this and uh and yeah and
and symbolism happens even in the most
even in the most historical sometimes
tellings of the story and you know it's
like to remember that
the city falls through the circus gate
is something that we all need to
remember right now in our world of
dilapidation correct
that's right so thanks for thanks mario
thanks for your time
pleasure pleasure really thank you